so when one looks at the relationship
with china today
uh it's certainly becoming more and more
adversarial
uh i wanted to start with maybe
how we got here because i am not a
student of history
but i was told that as i was growing up
that globalization was a good thing and
that when countries did business
together
this reduced the ability for those
countries to go to war and it increased
the uh and increased the chances that
democracy
and human rights would increase when
around the world and with those
different partners and when we look at
the united states engaging china
net net net over these last 20 or 30
years
has this been a successful endeavor for
america
and for democracy for the people of
china
well jason as you're accurately pointing
out the big picture
that i think provides a lot of the
framing for what we're living through
today
is that we are in the early stages of a
new kind of a cold war between the
united states and china
and unfortunately in the united states
we've had a tendency to forget
that china has as much agency as we do
in the u.s china relationship in other
words they're not a non-active player
we've known from leaked ccp documents
that date back to 2013 that
xi jinping had every intention to avoid
being the mikhail gorbachev of china
he saw the ussr's attempts to liberalize
as the key reason for the collapse of
the soviet union
and in fact in january of 2013 he
delivered a speech saying as much
to members of the central committee so
since then
she has also outlined a lot of different
plans that paint a naked ambition
to dominate the world's technology
companies
which has led several prominent national
security professionals
including the current head of the fbi to
conclude that
china's long-term aim isn't to be one of
several superpowers
but it's to be the world's only
superpower and that raises
some serious questions for democracies
so the writing's been on the wall for
some time
and china has backed up a lot of their
rhetoric with action
aggressively engaging in what the us
military calls grayzone conflict
which typically refers to attacks on an
adversary
that fall just short of the conventional
threshold of war
we call them grayzone because these
tactics are
often said to be in the murky gray zone
between war and peace
and just to cite a few examples by some
accounts
up to 90 percent of the world's fentanyl
compounds are made in china
and are all for export the vast majority
of which go to the united states where
35
000 americans die from fentanyl
overdoses
every single year china's unfair trade
practices has produced a bilateral trade
deficit
in goods that's the size of a g20
economy
just to put things in perspective
they've blocked nearly
every american content platform
including facebook twitter
github google youtube reddit just to
name a few
the level of ip theft that they've
engaged in has been referred to by the
former head of cybercom
as the greatest transfer of wealth in
human history
and the fbi announced that they now open
a china-related investigation every 10
hours
which paints color on the scope of
china's corporate espionage operations
in the united states
they're actively working to dislocate
the dollar status
as the world's reserve currency through
bilateral currency swap agreements
with a number of african countries as
well as russia as well as through
new institutional mechanisms like the
asian infrastructure and investment bank
and of course more recently they've
sought to export their model of
authoritarianism around the world
so peace on those terms jason and a
piece that's predicated on the united
states abdicating
so many of its core interests is as as
george orwell
once described it's a piece that's not
really a piece and
that's why in the last three years or so
we've seen policymakers in the united
states
increasingly awaken to the comprehensive
nature of the threat
posed by the chinese communist party